enemies of the kremlin
opposition politician alexei navalny
former spy sergey skripal and his
daughter yulia
all allegedly poisoned with a russian
novichok nerve agent
questions mounting for president
vladimir putin
using not again is clearly a signal that
there's a sense of impunity uh that
there's a sense that there is no
uh come back for the people who are
using this in
in russia the russian agents and so
you'll get back to our question about
whether president putin knows about this
uh or doesn't know about this and it
seems you can't have it both ways if he
doesn't know about it means that he's
not in charge and that nobody cares
about what he's saying or thinking
if he does know about it uh that means
that he is palpable
and he's giving this a nod and a wink to
what's going
on in russia and outside russia the
skripals were targeted in salisbury two
years ago
the uk accused russia's military
intelligence agency the gru
it identified these two men seen here on
the streets of salisbury on the day of
the attack
the kremlin denied the claims the
suspects
even saying they were tourists we
naturally were going there to see the
stonehenge old serum in the cathedral
but it didn't work out because of this
slush the whole city was covered with
slush
we got wet so we went back to the train
station and took the first train to go
back
the uk and its allies punished moscow
expelling dozens of russian diplomats
but the news novichok has been used
again
will be a cause for deep concern
these novichoks came
from the russian chemical warfare
program
developed in the 60s 70s and 80s
although in 2017 the russians declared
they'd got rid of all their chemical
weapons
so that was not the case but certainly
novichok
it's incredibly toxic uh probably 50 000
times more toxic than a
molecule of chlorine that you know is is
a chemical that's readily available
but the russians and allegedly it would
appear the russians
favor using toxic chemicals
to carry out assassinations the skripals
survived their novichok poisoning
knowledge of how to treat the toxin
could help to save mr navalny
but how to stop this banned chemical
weapon from being used once more
debra haynes sky news